the Black Forest is a wooded mountain
range in the state of baden-württemberg
in southwestern Germany in the spa town
of Oba vole [ __ ] the Hirsch in hotel and
restaurant is a favorite with tourists
its menu features almost exclusively
regional dishes a bahut young Hans is
the fourth generation of his family to
take on the business he runs it together
with his wife Renata Gaston fish the
transit has been around since 1609 just
a few years ago we had a big celebration
for our 400th anniversary what we value
above all at our restaurant is offering
very good service and using very good
ingredients in our cuisine
a behad young Hans buys his ingredients
locally like the cherries that are the
key ingredient in today's euro Max
recipe black forest cake does vasiliki
of black forest cherries are very
popular the most popular of any fruit in
our region they sell very well they
seafood for Java
back in the kitchen a behad young Hans
has everything ready to go
finally for a black forest cake you need
eggs flour sugar and of course the
cherries will be soaking in liqueur some
cocoa powder gelatine and this wonderful
quiche liqueur he got the recipe from
his father first separate the eggs for
the batter beat the egg whites
beforehand with a mixer and then fold in
the yolks and sugar
then add flour and wheat or corn starch
finally fold cocoa powder into the
mixture make the finished batter for 20
minutes at 160 degrees Celsius in the
meantime Heath the gelatin and Kirsch a
colorless cherry brandy slice the
finished cake base into three layers now
we moisten the black forest cake
thoroughly with kish blossom then cover
the cake layer with sour cherries which
have been soaked in Kirsch the gelatine
with the Kish is stirred into the cream
spread the gelatin whipped cream mixture
over the cherries to form the next layer
set the last cake layer on top and cover
it all with whipped cream and garnish
with rosettes chocolate shavings give
this monument to calories it's familiar
look with cherries on top of course but
in summary temperatures the cake should
be kept in the fridge to keep it fresh
in plenty percentage well I'd say
basically the black forest cake is the
fastest cake in the world you just have
to have the knack for it the trick is to
get the cash and the gelatine into the
cream at the right moment so the whipped
cream doesn't curdle so here's our
homemade black forest cake born Appetit
it can be enjoyed as a dessert or
together with afternoon tea black forest
cake a recipe with a long tradition
behind it
you
you